[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le caillou c'est la france et le caillou
c'est plus que c'est plus que la france
c'est la place de la france sur le
pacifique c'est la place de l'union
européenne sur le pacifique c'est un
enjeu déterminant pour nous ce
référendum les républicains depuis le
début sont engagés dans ce référendum
sont engagés dans la construction de la
nouvelle calédonie et des perspectives
qui vont s'ouvrir à partir de ce
référendum il n'ya pas d'autre place
pour la nouvelle calédonie que la place
dans la connaissez mon engagement
personnel pour la nouvelle calédonie j'y
suis allé à plusieurs reprises tous les
dirigeants et l'air sont des amis je les
ai régulièrement au téléphone je les
rencontre régulièrement les uns et les
autres bien entendu pierre frogier mais
c'est aussi virginie ruffenach c'est
aussi thierry santa qui est encore
hugues a il ya quelques jours il y a un
lien permanent mais aussi un vrai lien
écrit parce que parce que vous êtes des
amis parce que je sais que on peut
compter on peut compter sur vous on a
besoin d'une mobilisation sans faille
parce que encore une fois c'est un enjeu
déterminant
on ne peut pas rater ce dernier
référendum on a besoin de vous on a
besoin d'une mobilisation sans faille et
c'est vraiment l'occasion de vous redire
les liens d'affection mais au delà de
l'affection les liens géostratégique on
a besoin du caillou et on a besoin de
sentir cette mobilisation importante je
les fais à différentes reprises que ce
soit à la commission que j'ai pu
présider sur l'avenir de nouvelle
calédonie à l'assemblée nationale que ce
soit à l'occasion des différents des
différents déplacements
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas rater ce
référent on ne peut pas le rater et ça
ça dépend bien sûr de vous sachez que
vous avez ici sur la métropole un
soutien sans faille des républicains
tous les dirigeants des républicains ont
toujours été avocat vos côtés et plus
que jamais en lui
[Musique]